du bist ein hund ich bin jeder kennt
batman alias bruce wayne der als kind
seine eltern verlor und so von paten
großgezogen wurde bevor er sich zum
superheld entwickelt hat und jetzt mit
verschiedensten technischen
errungenschaften das börse bekam genau
wie batman wir unsere kleine mai auch
allein bis sophie und ich sie aus dem
tierheim abgeholt mai und batman also
eine ganze menge gemeinsam und da ist es
jetzt nur der nächste logische schritt
dass meine augen superheld wird ehrlich
gesagt warten wir jetzt auch schon seit
über drei jahren drauf deswegen wie
immer ein bisschen auf die sprünge
helfen und
zwar genau wie bei batman mit einem
hightech kettet dass wir fähigkeiten
verleiht die andere hunde wohl eher
nicht haben
und dabei ziemlich ängstlich ist ist sie
im profi darin unbemerkt herum zu
schleichen und zu beobachten was andere
so treiben um herauszufinden ob man
ihnen vertrauen kann womit klar ist dass
mein superspion wird und ein spionage
heitz band bekommt auf dass selbst die
besten geheimagenten neidisch werden
dieses video wird unterstützt vom
animationsfilm dc league aus superbad
zuerst überlege ich mir was das heißt
eigentlich alles können soll im mai auf
ihren geheimen missionen zu unterstützen
auf jeden fall eine eingebaute live
kamera und mikrofon ein gps tracker eine
fernsteuerbare taschenlampe und eine art
lautsprecher um ehrlich zu sein diesmal
senna s bahn auch ein bisschen dazu
gedacht um mai auszuspionieren wir
gesagt haben wir sie aus dem tierheim
und die kleine hat in der vergangenheit
nicht so schöne erfahrungen gemacht
deswegen sie starke angst vor fremden
hat und auch meine kleine panikattacke
kriegt damals in köln hat sie sich sogar
mal von der leine losgerissen und ist
mit vollgas über die straßen gedonnert
weil sie sich beim gassi gehen komplett
grundlos erschrocken hat worauf wir sie
drei tage lang tag und nacht gesucht
haben eine millionenstadt das kind zwar
dass gott sondern noch mal gut aus und
seitdem wir nicht mein köln wo ein blitz
die kleine richtig halte durch den
garten versteckt sich dabei auch mal
ganz gern in den kleinen waldstück das
wäre oder schleicht sich in den
nachbarstaaten und sie hat sogar schon
mal das ein oder andere mal katzenfutter
geklaut deshalb eine kamera damit man
sieht was sie gerade zieht ein track
karte wenn man weiß wo sie gerade steckt
und eine taschenlampe und lautsprecher
der piepsen kann dann wird man ihre
genaue und exakte position und richtung
erkennen kann zusammen mit pascal der
hier übrigens letzte woche angefangen
hat zu arbeiten und vor allem was
elektronik angeht ab sofort bei unseren
videos mithilfe wer hat zusammen mit dem
habe ich eine einkaufsliste angefertigt
von bauteilen die uns das alles
ermöglichen werden diese bauteile sind
jetzt gestellt und die müssen natürlich
noch im gehäuse deswegen habe ich mir
jetzt schon 3d modelle von jedem
einzelnen haushalte runtergeladen dann
bin ich genau dieses gehäuse
konzentrieren kann schon bevor die teile
da sind anfangen tue ich mit der groben
äußeren form des gehäuses eine box mit
einer konkaven rundum auf der seite wo
später mal meist als sein wird dann
entstehen hier zwei lassen durch die das
eigentliche heißt man es durch gefädelt
werden kann bevor ich die kamera an
ihren platz positionieren ich ziehe mir
auch alle anderen elektronikteile
innerhalb des gehäuses zurecht damit sie
auf möglichst kleinem raum zusammen
passen und man sie gut miteinander
vertragen kann natürlich brauchen wir
auch noch batterien nach dem wirklich
alles an seinem rechten platz ist
konstruiere ich sämtliche halterungen
der einzelnen elektronikkomponenten und
zuletzt auch die einlassungen für die
schrauben die die beiden hälften später
einmal zusammen halten werden damit das
virtuelle real wird willst der 3d
drucker angekurbelt die idee für das
spionage als band kommt übrigens nicht
von ungefähr ich habe letztens ein
trailer vom neuen actionfilm dc league
auf super platz gesehen der am 28 07
also heute ins kino kommt und daher die
inspiration
nachdem kumpels zum gassi gehen
vielleicht lasse ich ihn lieber schlafen
alles klar ich bin okay kripo wir gegen
das in dem animationsfilm von dem dieses
video übrigens unterstützt wird geht es
um die zwei unzertrennlichen freunde
superman und sein hund crypto beide
besitzen die gleichen superkräfte und
kämpfen in die metropole ist seite an
seite gegen das verbrechen aber als
superman und der rest der justice league
entführt werden muss crypto seinen
besten freunden superman retten sieh mal
einer an wenn das nicht die justice
league ist
aber nicht alleine denn hat
unterstützung von unter anderem bett und
aids und dessen multitool als band die
inspiration für myspace bahnstadt wollte
den film sehen dann klickt auf den link
in der video beschreibung für die
spielzeiten in einem kino in eurer nähe
und buch durch bequem direkt ticket sagt
der druck ist fertig jetzt schaut man ob
das was ich da verzapft haben auch
irgendwas taugt ich habe das hier die
ganze elektronik freistil da verbaut
werden freund die müssen jetzt eben rein
ich war mal an mit der kamera ps ultra
klein ja also das von meran er passt das
bild aber später ja so rein geklebt der
computer das mikrofon rein das passt
nicht an sein und gucken dass andere
dinge als ich dachte da muss ich noch
mal nach hier der gps sensor und der
passt richtigkeit 1 media service frei
ist einem aufgehoben er hält auch schon
gekümmert und war und die andere hälfte
der komplett die batterie rein die
passte auch ganz gut rein und dann kommt
die abdeckung der die union kein absatz
den steckt minuten rein und clips oben
rein und dann kann man die einfach wie
sie zuschauen und mechanismus als recht
professionell er ist auch direkt mal im
battery mechanismus ihr umbauen
er ist es zu glauben dass jetzt einfach
mal drin hängt es sieht einfach aus als
wäre es also wenn es irgend ein
richtiges produkt also schon gesehen was
meine strategie um das ding
herauszukriegen
scoop elektronik oder um das zu
verhindern versuche ich jetzt mal was
was bei gopro akkus verwendung findet
also komm rein wird festgestellt
dass toll geil allein der partie
überzeugt mich schon hart da hält noch
einmal diese coole weiteren kraftakt und
dann würde ich vorschlagen schrauben
fest batterie ist randy passt gut rein
jetzt fehlt noch das teil das die
spannung von der batterie von 9 volt auf
die 5 volt unerträglich die wir brauchen
können sollten ganz zeugt ja das passt
super wohl rein und dann noch das ist
allerletzte sinken die sind kein thema
sagt er macht einfach nur kraft findet
man die man auch hört ok weswegen auch
ein bisschen enger mit hält das mikrofon
braucht mehr platz und die kleine led
hier wie ist nicht genau dabei der
aussparung und deswegen verstehe ich
auch mal ist damit die letzte die mängel
in unserer v1 behäbig also das led loch
war übrigens deswegen nicht genau über
der led weil die led in dem modell das
sich heruntergeladen hat falsch
positioniert und doppelt so groß war wie
bei unserem echten bauteil aus v1 wird
also bei 2
[Musik]
das ist neutral mit den verbesserungen
hat allerdings auch ein paar
verschlechterungen die druckqualität an
sich ist also nicht ganz zurück geworden
darum muss jetzt ein bisschen
nachbessern
gibt es ein paar überschüsse die dann
nicht so unbedingt sein sollten dann
einmal die ganz kleinen löcher nachbarn
weil sie ein bisschen zu eng geworden
ja das ist meine kamera jetzt ist die
allee auf immer genau genug das mikrofon
das passt es auch ein wie angegossen
hier
sind noch ein ja gut das passt eher ein
das passt ja einst und jetzt kann ja
auch diese beiden hälften
zusammenstecken jetzt ganz zusammen
schrauben und auf allen seiten
gleichmäßig und zack ist das teil fertig
passt alles wunderbar ins gehäuse das
kommt jetzt ein halsband und kommen dann
an den hals von altmeilern gut zu wissen
wir allerdings noch ob diese kamera
jetzt von irgendwelchen haaren überdeckt
wird meist
so anprobe das verschlucken und
[Musik]
die kamera für ein bisschen verdeckt
leider konnten jetzt um die seien aber
dass wir arbeit also da sehen wir die
marbach kal
da wir meist wunderschönes fällt
natürlich nicht abrasieren analysieren
wir mal wie sich die kameraposition so
verhält die beste sicht hätte man
bestimmt wenn die kamera hier oben wäre
aber dann würde das heißt band
automatisch immer wieder nach unten
rutschen dafür dass es heißt bei uns
deswegen ohnehin unten sein muss ist der
winkel in die kamera ein feld aber
zumindest diesen bild nach zu urteilen
schon sehr gut lediglich die haare
könnte noch ein problem werden aber wer
selbst lange haare hat weiß dass ein
paar haare vor dem auge die sich zwar
schon einschränken aber weniger als man
denkt bevor ich mir jetzt also die mühe
macht und alles komplett neu konstruiert
will ich erst mal einen blick durch
meist bionade kamera werfen und die hat
pascal in der zwischenzeit sogar schon
programmiert und verkabeln
[Musik]
hallo ich hab ihn heißt natürlich hallo
uns als band
verbindet sich jetzt stehe ich die
kamera sie sehe ich geil meinte
reichsbahn um mein gott neu ist das
heißt man das wissen schief die man
hatte viel mehr bock zu chillen hanno
meint das ist gras das ist die haare
sind schon gut im weg meckern ja okay er
die kamera passt auf jeden fall sind
paare dabei aber es passt wenn man die
led an zumal meine leuchte ist
geil
led aus und an und aus und an aus das
sichtfeld ist gut genug ich entscheide
mich also das gehäuse nicht nochmal
abzuändern mai ist jetzt nicht nur ein
wachhund sondern auch einen überwachungs
und der nacht dank der led sieht und
auch gesehen wird und mit etwas kälter
mir dann noch ein weiteres problem
gelöst dass ich fast am coolsten findet
zwar kennst du ja wenn du hier im garten
arbeitet zudem als machst oder als du
das fehlt hier gebaut hast und dann hast
du dir mal draußen weil die sogar und
draußen sein und sofort und nicht ganz
da drin haben wir kennen das problem die
meist dann aus wie es auf einmal da oben
rein und dann habe ich sie nicht mehr
gefunden und weil musst du ständig auf
die man aufpassen aber du musst du
eigentlich irgendwas machen profit ja
und zwar entführe ich jetzt mal die
meisten etwas mit ihm einfach weggehen
wenn du jetzt etwas machst
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ok kommen hier
voll cool hast das gefühl dass film ein
problem aus dem leben entfernt wurde
definitiv
allem ein problem haben sich in luft
aufgelöst mai ist jetzt ein echter
superhund und wenn ihr noch mehr helden
action sehen wollt verpasst nicht den
animationsfilm dc league auf super pace
der heute in allen kinos erscheint der
link zu den sendezeiten der kinos in
eurer nähe ist in der video beschreibung
und ich bin damit raus macht's gut